عزيزي الرئيس أردوغان،
الإرهاب ضد إسرائيل في أسابيع
حماس بعد الهجوم
جهزت إييي تفسيراتك إييي فقط
ليس في ألمانيا. حسنًا، إنه حلف شمال الأطلسي آخر
بين دول التحالف
كما تسبب في إزعاج EEE
تعترف بحق إسرائيل في الوجود
لأن هذه الدولة في ألمانيا
هو الفهم
حسنا، من ناحية أخرى، إسرائيل فاشية
قلت الدولة هي دولة
قلت أنه كان البريد الذي
هناك مبرر لهذا ولماذا
أنت تقول الإبادة الجماعية والجيش الإسرائيلي
هجوم ضد حماس والمئات من
إلى منظمة تقتل الناس في إسرائيل و
في حلف الناتو بأكمله تقريبًا
حسنًا، إنها منظمة إرهابية من قبل الحلفاء.
ما نوع المنظمة التي تُعرف بها هذه المنظمة؟
حسنًا، إنها تسمى منظمة التحرير.
حسنًا، يمكنك تحديد اللغة التركية والألمانية.
هل تعرض علاقتهما للخطر؟
أريد أن أسأل وداخل الناتو
وهذا يعرض التعاون للخطر.
أريد أن أسأل هل أنت و
حسنًا
على سبيل المثال، فيما يتعلق بصناعة الدفاع
40 وحدة للصناعات الدفاعية إلى تركيا
يوروفايتر في الطلب
حسنًا، ألمانيا ستقبل بهذا
فعلا
بادئ ذي بدء، حلف شمال الأطلسي
واحدة من الدول الرائدة هي الأولى
نحن دولة من بين الدول الخمس
مثل تركيا، تعتبر تركيا دولة عادية في حلف شمال الأطلسي
ليست دولة ولكن الخمسة الأوائل
في حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو) وداخله حاليًا
في الفكر
أيا كان رأيه
سواء روسيا أوكرانيا
من هو الجانب الذي يقف عليه الجميع؟
تركيا تقف بجانب أوكرانيا
كما أننا نجتمع أيضًا مع أوكرانيا
كما أننا نجري محادثات مع روسيا من بينها
أي تمييز
نحن لا نفعل ذلك، ولكن 33 مليون طن
قمح
كل تلك الحبوب إلى أوروبا عبر الممر
نحن الذين أخذونا إلى أفريقيا
نحن الآن
مرة أخرى تقول المئات منهم انظروا إليك
أنا لا أقول المئات
الآلاف
فلسطينية الآن
هل قتلت إسرائيل؟
قتل
هل دمرت المستشفيات؟
هل يضرب أماكن العبادة؟
هل يضرب الكنائس؟
كمسلم، أنا منزعج من هذا
انت مسيحي
كما ضربت هذه الكنائس
لا يزعجك
لماذا لديك موقف تجاههم؟
ولا تتخذ أي موقف ضدهم.
ضع هذا لنا
عند نقطة في المنطقة
يهودي
ولا فرق بين المسيحيين والمسلمين
يجب أن تكون هناك معركة ضد معاداة السامية
إذا كان هناك صراع، هذا الصراع
أنا أول زعيم في العالم يعطي
كنت وأنظر إليها الآن
ألمانيا
هذا الكثير من الدعم المالي لإسرائيل
لأنك أعطيت
ويتحدث أيضا عن يوروفايتر
ألمانيا تعطي أو
من ينتج الطائرات الحربية في العالم؟
ألمانيا فقط
هل من الممكن الحصول على هذه للعمل من أماكن كثيرة؟
نحن نقدم وغير مأهولة حاليا
تركيا أيضا من حيث الطائرات الحربية
واحدة من الدول الرائدة
إلى الوضع
لقد وصل أحد الصحفيين
يهددنا بهذا
لا تسألنا مثل هذه الأسئلة التي
لتكن الأسئلة ضميرية وإنسانية
نحن نقدم لك الإجابات بهذه الطريقة.
هيا نعطي